- Hello!
- Hey guys, hi!
- [Kelly] Meet Utkarsh, meet Vanessa.
I don't know if y'all have met before.
- Hi Vanessa.
- Hi.
- I feel like we have a very talented
couch of voices right now.
(audience cheers)
- It's a very, very-
- That rap was ridiculous, right?
- It was ridiculous.
I literally was talking about
it the whole commercial break,
cause I feel not talented.
(E.G. laughs)
But I have to ask you,
you were on The Voice
before I was on The Voice.
- Yes, yes.
- And not ask you, I have to tell you
I loved your version of Breathe.
That main bit when you, I
think, was that in the Blinds?
Is that what you did in the Blinds?
- Yes, I did in my Blind, yeah.
- Oh my God, it was so good!
I think, was it season five?
- I was on season five of The Voice.
And I would've never thought
I was gonna be on The Voice.
- I know, so I have to ask you
cause you had all these
accolades beforehand
and usually people go on there
because you're trying to make
it and you'd already made it.
So I was wondering like,
what was your intention,
other than the fact that
you're an amazing singer?
- Oh, thank you so much.
Okay, so here's what really happened.
So I had gone through
this little period of time
where I was sort of not doing
what I loved to do anymore.
I just stopped doing all
the things I loved to do.
And I woke up one day and
decided, you know what?
I am not as happy as I could be.
So I'm gonna say yes to
everything that I love.
So every day I would say yes to,
someone would call and say
"Do you wanna do this?"
And I'd be like, "No."
And then they'd be like,
"Do you wanna do that?"
I'm like, "Yes!"
Like whatever was a hell
yes in my body I was doing
so a girlfriend of mine asked
me to host a music show.
She said, "Would you
host this thing with me?"
And I was like... No,
first she asked me to sing.
I said yes.
Then she asked me to host it.
I said, yes.
And then she said, "I hope you're not mad
but I got you an audition for The Voice."
And I was like, "Oh no, I can't, I can't."
And I was like, I have to say yes
because I love singing, you know?
It's my joy.
And I went on and made it on Team Blake.
- [Kelly] Your rasp is so cool.
(audience cheers)
You probably still would've picked Blake
if I'd have been there, I know.
- I would've picked your
team, for Pete's sake,
I would have picked you, Kelly.
(Kelly laughs)
- I love that you can
just do voices like that.
So wait, how did you get
into doing cartoon voices?
- Okay, I'd say cartoon
voices got into me, really,
because I didn't really grow up thinking
like "I'm gonna be a cartoon.
I'm gonna go be a cartoon one day."
- I know, it's a random job to get into.
- Yeah. I mean, I'd done movies.
I did a lot of different movies
and my thing was characters.
And so I could, as you know, as a singer,
you can contort your voice.
And I don't know what happened.
I just, I did a play.
I got to do all these
different voices in a play.
And then suddenly someone
heard me in the play
doing all these voices and
said, you should do voiceover.
And I was like, oh, I don't know.
You know, I don't do that.
But I did.
I went on my first audition for cartoon
and it was Tommy Pickles
on Rugrats was my first.
(audience cheers)
- That's your first.
- Wait, was that the question?
- No, I just love that
that was your first,
I'm like "Wow, it worked out."
I know that you've both
actually done animation work.
So isn't it, I love doing that.
I think it's fun to go and
do like voiceover stuff.
- So much fun.
I did my first one
recently for My Little Pony
and I was like, this
is the best thing ever.
(audience cheers)
So cool.
- You have a great voice.
- Thank you.
- You could do a ton of-
I'm sure you do.
- I love it.
I'm like, doing the little kids' voices
are always my favorite though.
- Yeah.
- They're so cute.
- Yeah they're just so...
they love them so much.
- I'm not gonna do my
voice in front of you.
You are a legend, there's no way.
Basically you just pitch it up.
You just go, "Hey!"
- That was great.
- That's me.
That's me doing you.
- Kinda yeah, and it just
really depends on like,
my favorite game is I look at things
and then I'd make up a
voice for it or a person
or you know whatever.
Like, you know, the flowers would be like,
"Ah, it's a bright and beautiful day."
You know? Like I would do that.
- Oh my gosh.
- Or like, you know, like
the pillow, I'd be like
"Oh, why don't you take a load off
and put your booty down here?
- Oh, so you're inspired
by what you're saying.
So we have to do a
commercial break but first,
you're also on an upcoming Go Gos tribute.
That's amazing.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So what song?
I've got the single 'We Got The Beat.'
And so I recut it and it's really fun.
- Oh my gosh.
And you're still singing and I love that.
- Yeah. I'm still singing
because it's the thing
I love to do the most.
So, you know, I just say-
- It brings so much joy.
- Yeah. It really does.
And like, to me, it's just beautiful.
- You know what though?
You'll get this and you all will get this.
You love singing, you love your voice.
Like it's such a gift to have,
like to be able to just sing
'cause it feels like so good.
- It does.
- It just feels really good.
Like if I'm doing it for
a show or just for myself
like at home, just singing,
it's just, it feels good.
It's like dancing.
It's like something that's
like done with your body.
- And I think chemistry
in your body changes.
I don't know if you, you know,
you sing, you know, you sing.
- Yeah.
- You are amazing.
- Well, I did stuff, I do stuff.
- And I gotta tell you.
Yeah, you do some stuff.
That was awesome.
- Do stuff.
- It's incredible.
- My kids love you by the way.
Oh, good, send them my love.
- We're all talking about
Princess Switch today.